publicitaires le gros matos sud radio
le petit déjeuner politique bienvenue
dans le grand matin se fait de radio
c'est le petit déjeuner politique d'eric
ciotti ce matin député l'est républicain
des alpes-maritimes et président de la
commission nationale d'investiture des
républicains bonjour eric ciotti bonjour
votre chef de groupe à l'assemblée
christian jacob demande d'une nouvelle
élection mais sans préciser laquelle
j'ai pas compris législatives
présidentielles ou autre qu'est ce qu'il
a voulu dire alors il n'a pas réclamé
formellement de nouvelles élections il a
dit simplement
il a souligné une évidence en démocratie
comme sans doute contient des
interrogations du meilleur moyen de se
relégitimer c'est l'élection
il soulignait la dérive de ce débat
interminable filandreux sans objectif
très concret que poursuit de façon très
politicienne emmanuel macron ça fait
cinq mois maintenant que le pays se
trouve dans une situation de conflits de
crises ça fait trois mois qu'on étire ce
grand débat et qui n'en finit pas de se
terminer
maintenant nous annonce peut-être des
mesures jusqu'en juillet est bien là
christian jacob a légitimement souligné
qu en démocratie le seul juge c'est les
lecteurs voilà donc s'il ya un doute il
y a la possibilité d'avoir un référendum
on l'a on en avait parlé les
républicains l'avaient réclamé au départ
puis un homme sur quoi sur des questions
qui sont des ces questions de société on
parle des institutions parle du pouvoir
d'achat des impôts nous nous avons
demandé grandvaux qu'il avait demandé un
référendum notamment sur la baisse de la
fiscalité égale sont pas de la blague
est une initiative des solutions c'est
au président de la république à un
moment de mesurer sa légitimité
qu'est ce qu'il voudrait que le débat
c'est de la communication
l'élection en démocratie n'y a que ça
qui compte
tout le reste ce sont des dès qu'ils
sont pipés ou des cartes qui sont
bienvenus
les élections parce qu'il ya des
européennes ça ne vous a pas échappé fin
mai déjà fait ça n'a pas échappé
c'est déjà une élection vous pensez que
ça va être quelque part une forme de
référendum ou pas en tout cas cette
élection pour la première fois depuis
2010 cette offre l'opportunité aux
français de sanctionner la politique
catastrophique de ce gouvernement
il faut que ces élections européennes
soient pour les français le vecteur de
leur mécontentement et l'expression leur
volonté de changer c'est pour ça qu'il
faut qu'ils fassent confiance aux
républicains avec françois-xavier
bellamy parce que nous avons une
opposition qui depuis le départ et
lucide
autour de laurent wauquiez qui a dénoncé
les dérives de ce pouvoir qui a dénoncé
son mépris des français
son mépris des territoires sa politique
injuste et inefficace
et aujourd'hui nous sommes les seuls
dans cette élection à éviter
l'alternative entre le chaos que
représentent les extrêmes
bon mais l'inefficacité puissant euro
series beac représente fédéralisme
représenteront pardon eric ciotti mais
l'alternative elle est à 13% sa stagné
en fait toujours ça avait un petit peu
décollé au début quand il y avait
françois xavier bellamy et sa
candidature et depuis ça n'avance plus
ça passe ou ça c'est vous qui le dites
quoi c'est le sait notre enquête en tout
cas tous les jours en tout cas érection
aller le 26 mai elle se cristallisera
dans les derniers jours
françois-xavier bellamy est un excellent
candidat qui a été choisie de façon très
pertinente par laurent wauquiez
renouvelle cette droite de valeurs de
conviction il donne une nouvelle image
aussi de la politique je crois que royal
à l'unanimité au sein des républicains
quand même on aurait voulu les deux plus
politique les questions elles étaient au
départ aujourd'hui je crois au contraire
il était devant notre groupe à
l'assemblée nationale à l'invitation de
christian jacob que l'unanimité elle est
de plus en plus au rendez vous donc nous
sommes dans une dynamique le score a
quasiment doublé depuis le début de la
campagne - on était très bas
on était très bas dans les sondages en
tout cas j'en conviens mais en tout cas
je crois que notre famille politique
elle s'impose de plus en plus bon après
les difficultés nous avons failli
disparaître monsieur macron voulu nous
éliminer et nous restons sa cible et
pour cela il utilise ça si je sais plus
tôt marine le pen de rationalité à
chaque fois oui mais juste le chaos
c'est une fausse qu'il ne parle pas
d'eux c'est une possible parce que il
sait très bien que face à marine le pen
c'est pour lui une assurance vie dont
nous nous refusons cette alternative
entre madame le pen pris aujourd'hui
nous conduirait en gros à la situation
que rencontrent nos amis anglais c'est
un chaos total
c'est sa position un chaos total et de
l'autre côté
aujourd'hui cette espèce de de
technocratie européenne qu'on veut
amplifier en votant pour madame
d'oiseaux qui elle vous parler de
dynamique de campagne
quand je voi enthousiasme que suscite la
candidature de madame l'oiseau qui
cumule quand même tout ce que les
français ne veulent plus la beauté knock
rassis le fédéralisme le maîtrisent le
mépris des électeurs donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on parle de mépris des
années nous avons le terrain nous avons
sept nous constituant cette alternative
une alternative responsable et crédible
et nous ne voulons plus de cette europe
qui a joué mais nous sommes et où soit
européen parce que l'europe elle a des
vertus qui nous protège
eric ciotti allant vous présidez de la
commission nationale d'investiture des
républicains la liste n'est pas bouclée
vous allez la boucler ce soir ce soir à
18 heures il ya des surprises qui vont
arriver là pour donner justement un
nouveau coup de booster peut-être à
votre campagne non si on a besoin bas
nous compléterons là
liste de la 28e place à la dernière avec
un équilibre territorial qui
représentera toutes les entreprises tous
les départements pas de pas de surprises
sont quelques uns des candidats les élus
locaux
oui ce sont des candidats implanté qui
représentent nos territoires c'est la
différence avec en marche
délia jaune où il ya des candidats hors
sol où il y à des camps joe haege atik
n'y a pas de dépasser les gilets jaunes
se sont au départ les français dont l'un
des candidats qui représente la france
qui représente nos territoires qui
représente aussi surtout l'expression
d'une politique de redressement pour
notre pays eric ciotti au moins 185 de
vos collègues parlementaires là ont
lancé cette idée d'un référendum
d'initiative partagée contre la
privatisation des aéroports de paris
est ce que vous y êtes vous favorable je
ne suis pas favorable à la privatisation
des aéroports de paris parce que c'est
un outil stratégique c'est une plate
forme d'accords héros portuaire
extrêmement importantes au plan
international donc vous êtes d'accord
se référant de ces initiatives est âgée
cette initiative c'est un outil de
souveraineté et personnellement je
considère que les conditions qui sont
posées ne sont pas suffisamment
protectrices pour notre indépendance
nationale un aéroport international
comme les aéroports de marie les
plateformes aéroportuaires roissy orly
ce sont des frontières aussi est dans la
situation que nous connaissons avec une
porosité de nos frontières avec une
crise migratoire hommage à discuter
d'accord vous êtes contre sur le
référendum d'initiative partagée
vous êtes favorable ou pas moi je fais
signer ou pendant les jeux ne l'est pas
ce n'est pas signé je ne suis pas
persuadé que quatre millions et demi de
français se mobilisent sur sur ce sujet
c'est parce que j'ai effectivement un
seul boguey
et à la fois un seuil des parlementaires
il est acquis il est atteint il y a un
regard du conseil constitutionnel c'est
la prochaine étape et ensuite il
faudrait plus de quatre millions et demi
de signal vous êtes contradictoires ce
matin vous dites il faut du référendum
là il ya une initiative d'un référendum
et vous dit non je vous dis que
personnellement je n'ai pas signé parce
que euh nan débat parlementaire m contre
rien demandé sur cette question je pense
personnellement sur quelles questions
vous verrez vous verrez si j'ai raison
ou tort je ne pense pas que quatre
millions et demi de français vont se
mobiliser sur cette question mais je
peux me tromper
oui bon un mot sur les municipales nice
1 c'est dans un an
la bataille est déjà engagée il y a eu
un sondage de la semaine dernière qui
vous mettez en bonne place face à
christian estrosi alors ce matin il ya
une nouvelle enquête ifop pour ses news
et là vous êtes battus dans tous les cas
de figure et christian estrosi seraient
même élu au premier tour s'il n'y avait
qu'un candidat républicain si je n'y
étais pas mais oui c'est ça parce que
vous y allez vraiment ou pas écoutez je
répondrai à se quereller dans sa famille
je répondrai à cette question bat
d'abord il faut savoir si on est
toujours dans la même famille politique
c'est une question qui qui longtemps
s'est posée pour christian estrosi
c'est d'ailleurs un peu aujourd'hui ce
qui suscite qui peut susciter ce débat
c'est le jeu de jean républicain la
fidélité à nos valeurs
il faudra lui lui demande et j'ai vu
qu'il avait c'est peut-être les
conséquences de ces enquêtes qui sont
très serrés vous évoquez une enquête
aujourd'hui d'un organisme qui en avait
déjà fait une à la demande de christian
estrosi il ya quelques mois
l'écart a en quelques mois était divisé
par deux
aujourd'hui moi je ne suis pas et je ne
suis pas candidat je pars li da
j'apporterai une réponse à ce jour je ne
suis pas candidat j'apporterai une
réponse donc je ne suis pas en campagne
christian estrosi les mois je regarde
qu'il y apporte confiance des niçois se
situer en n'étant pas candidat à 30%
je crois que c'est un site de confiance
des niçois si tenté que c'est un autre
enquête reflètent la réalité vous
soulignez qui n'a eu notre part ce que
disent et enquête c'est qu'aujourd'hui
un match qui est rouvert manis qui a
lésé les valeurs et christian estrosi
cas c'est ce que semble dire c'est dans
les enquêtes mais je pense tout ça avec
beaucoup de recul
et puis nous verrons bien moi je veux
servir nice pourquoi je veux apporter
des réponses
il y à des problématiques politiques on
les a évoqués de clarification dans
notre famille politique parce qu'on ne
peut pas d'or et deux dents peut pas
soutenir emmanuel normand et notre
famille politique
en même temps ça c'est pas possible et
c'est ce que je reprochais disposition
estrosi
c'est ce que lui ont reproché nucléaire
vous serez derrière lui est ce qu'on
peut imaginer eric ciotti que vous soyez
quand même derrière christian estrosi
pour sachant que vous êtes dans la même
famille c'est ce que l'on reproché les
électeurs de notre famille politique
notamment puisque nous avons eu un débat
à l'automne dernier à la présidence de
notre famille politique en tout cas dans
des circonscriptions sur ces deux lignes
celle d'un rapprochement avec emmanuel
macron celle d'une opposition ferme dans
la fidélité à nos valeurs a ensuite il
ya des débats il y à des débats de fond
aujourd'hui notamment la question de la
fiscalité est sage en fait une question
de principe nice a été là avec sa
métropole la ville qui a le plus
augmenté la fiscalité oui ça vous
intéresse pas
10 soit nice est une ville qui a une
dette très importante
donc moi je veux apporter mais des
réponses qui a recréé j'emploie le seul
député républicain ait eu à nice donc
j'ai une responsabilité vis-à-vis des
niçois et vis-à-vis de tout confié selon
le mot de la fin
christian eriksen tiges et le mode avec
cécile de ménibus
oui ça tombe bien vous fassiez un lapsus
patrick roger hier c'était grand prix de
l'humour politique aux classes club
vous avez reçu le prix du bio alors du
nom de son créateur de jean miot et vous
parliez vous évoquez à l'assemblée
nationale gérard collomb écoutez nous
avons un ministre de l'intérieur qui est
déjà l'extérieur du gouvernement
ma question est simple monsieur le
premier la parole
en fait vous pourriez faire du one man
show dont vous l'avez écrit ça c'était
écrit sur votre papier cette phrase elle
était oui elle était à l'it vous partez
pas improviser bien sûr que les élites
moi mais c'est vrai que c'était dans ce
contexte
dans ce contexte un peu ahuri sens où
dans cette séance de questions au
gouvernement du 2 octobre le premier
ministre nous disait que gérard collomb
était encore au gouvernement et puis il
apprend lui mais manifestement à sa
grande surprise qu'il confirme sa
démission m
on a eu pendant une heure le départ en
direct de gérard collomb les niveaux sur
vous il faut en avoir en tout cas il
faut en avoir parce que c'est l'antidote
contre la grosse tête ça peut arriver en
politique ça arrive à beaucoup et donc
avoir de l'autodérision avoir un peu de
recul ne pas se prendre au sérieux alors
qu'on fait des choses sérieuses sérieuse
et comme on a malheureusement à ce sujet
à traiter des sujets très grave ce qui
est mon cas puisque l'assemblée
nationale je suis beaucoup les questions
de sécurité terrorisme immigration
bonjour juste marie que c'est la voix de
l'intérieur de moi même je suis quand
même beau gosse la même coupe de cheveux
qu'alain juppé
merci invité ce matin de sud radio reste
avec nous dany mauro dans quelques
instants
tout à l'heure dans sept minutes mais
restez avec nous cette heure 57
[Musique]